[Applaudissements]
qui nous dirigent qui dirigent nos vies
qui dirige le monde
la politique la banque la religion la
famille peut-être les médias ou
peut-être les gaffes à vous savez les
google apple facebook amazon nos amis du
web
vaste question n'est ce pas et bien ce
qui dirige le plus assurément le monde
ce sont nos sens alors aristote nous l'a
déjà dit depuis l'antiquité nous fait
même passer le message
rien de notre intelligence qu'ils ne
soient passés par nos sens alors je suis
designer et je me plie aux préceptes
d'aristote
je mets mes sens à contribution pour
créer des objets qui s'adresse enfin je
l'espère à l'intelligent sensorielle
alors j'aimerais vous faire part de
cette intelligence d'essence alors elle
nous dépasse souvent mais elle nous
construit absolument
c'est simple comme l'enfance comme mon
enfance j'ai cinq ans imaginez imaginez
vraiment parce que
ma chambre jouxte l'atelier de l'atelier
de tapisserie de ma mère le matin je me
réveille au bruit de son atelier et de
son activité le rythme mécanique de sa
machine à coudre industrielle le sol
mouillé de la vapeur du fer à repasser
ou le crissement du tissu qu'on déchire
fait pas mal mais ya l'odeur aussi le ce
n'est pas le l'odeur du café qui
effleure mes narines
mais l'odeur du tissu 9 qui sans
l'animal ou le synthétique et qui est
déplié ou remuer quand je rentre dans
son atelier absolument lieu magique pour
moi enfant il est totalement encombré de
morceaux de tissus qui sont prêts à
devenir des sièges des tentures des
rideaux j'ai toujours cinq ans imaginez
hélas j'accompagne mon grand père qui
est entrepreneur de travaux publics et
je l'accompagnent dans la tournée de ses
chantiers et bien encore aujourd'hui je
me délecte de l'odeur de ciment frais
qui parfume et toutes nos visites
alors voilà je dis que ce métier de
designer je les construis dans cette
enfance aux sources
déjà de toutes les sensations que mes
mais faisait familiaux m'ont proposé et
aussi à tous les souvenirs accumulés
enfin m'a donné le goût de la matière ça
m'a donné le goût de la forme
et puis la capacité à imaginer réaliser
des objets qui sont utiles pratiques
j'espère poétique complexe technique est
absolument sensorielle en fin de compte
j'essaye depuis quelques années de faire
des objets qui ont du sens et des sens
mais je ne suis pas tout seul à avoir
construit mon métier sur les sensations
de l'enfance avant d'être écrivain
proust a été un enfant
ces sensations premières ont été le clé
les clés du succès de toute sa vie
d'adulte et surtout de toute son
activité d'écrivain qui ne connaît pas
sa madeleine
ça a l'air d'être partagée promis promis
je ne vous ferai pas la lecture des sept
tomes de la recherche du temps perdu
mais je vous offrirai avec quelques
extraits le mécanisme de son
intelligence sensorielle pour que nous
puissions comprendre nos propres
histoires sensorielle alors proust
adultes 1 dimanche se fait servir par sa
mère une tasse de thé avec une petite
madeleine
et puis il d'une façon tout à fait
classique
ils mangent cette madeleine et il boit
son thé et là ils tressaille de plaisir
et commencent à se poser la question de
savoir si ce plaisir et bien il est
temps lui aussi plutôt c'est lui ce
plaisir et surtout que cette ils
appellent ça une essence que cette
essence d'un coup juste à la dégustation
de la madeleine lui permet de se sentir
plus du tout médiocre plus du tout
comptage en plus du tout mortel dit il
imaginez cinq secondes lors l'économie
d'anxiolytiques que nous ferions tous si
nous puisse nous pouvons déguster une
madeleine et nous puissions nous sentir
absolument exceptionnel à la dégustation
d'une manne donne évidemment pas
n'importe laquelle de madeleine plutôt
la nôtre alors je vous ferai grâce mais
proulx s'interroge de nombreuses pages
jusqu'à la révélation est la leur à la
révélation c'est un souvenir d'enfance
et il dit souvenir tout d'un coup le
souvenir m'est apparu eh bien c'était le
dimanche matin quand il allait chez sa
tante léonie à combret elle lui donnait
une des petits morceaux de madeleine
qu'elles trempaient dans son infusion de
thé alors la vue de la madeleine quand
ils avaient dégusté ça avec sa maman ça
n'y avait absolument rien procurer mais
simplement la saveur et l'odeur de la
madeleine qui ont fait la différence
lui dit
proust que la saveur et l'odeur se sont
comme des âmes à se rappeler l'édifice
immense du souvenir et vous quelles
sensations vous envahir quand vous
voulez c'est un peu le temps d'y penser
qu'elle madeleine vous fait succomber
quelle sensation de l'enfance construit
votre dit votre vos habitudes vos envies
vos préférences d'adultes et peut-être
vos métiers alors est ce que par hasard
l'un d'entre vous êtes addict l'odeur de
chiffrer est ce que ce serait pas parce
que vous étiez caché dans la panière de
linge à repasser quand vous étiez petit
alors pas que des choses sympas pourquoi
vous détestez le goût de la betterave
est ce que par hasard ça ne vous feriez
pas penser à la cantine du primaire et
si je vous chantonnez cinq petites notes
tintin tintin tintin est ce que vous ne
pensez pas subitement au aux collants de
monsieur dimanche et que ça vous met pas
un petit peu dans dans la joie alors
pourquoi instinctivement tous ces
souvenirs vous donne quelques frissons
de bonheur dans l'ostalgie peut-être de
la version ou peut-être simplement de
l'énergie et bien parce que nous ne
savons pas vraiment mais nous à
possédons des outils absolument
exceptionnel qui sont individuelles
personnel est totalement perfectionner
ce sont nos sens sur notre corps nos
émotions sur notre cerveau c'est pas mal
il faut négliger ni les oublier
aujourd'hui même si nous vivons dans un
monde virtuel où le virtuel rime avec
mutations de la société
nous devons penser à nos sens et
justement les neurosciences bonne
science nous donne les clés d'accès à
tous ces outils
elles nous permettent de comprendre et
de décrypter
pourquoi l'odeur de ciment frais ou la
femme fameuse madeleine nous
construisent alors schématiquement le
cerveau est différent en périphérie et
en son centre
en périphérie les cartésiens il fournit
une pensée rationnelle et surtout il
s'occupe du langage au centre c'est le
royaume de la madeleine royaume
formidable de la sensation et de
l'instinct de survie
et puis de l'émotion et des souvenirs et
surtout surtout le cerveau central
décide mais évidemment il a délégué le
langage en périphérie c'est pourquoi
quelques fois vous pouvez comprendre une
situation les faits les chiffres les
détails et vous avez du mal à la valider
vous trouvez pas le mot de justes et
souvent vous pensez je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais ça je ne le sens pas
anormal c'est le cerveau de la madeleine
qui contrôle votre décision et votre
émotion mais pas le langage alors c'est
pour ça aussi que des marketeurs des
concepteurs des industriels des
innovateurs même des designers seulement
ceux qui sont pas sensorielle bien sûr
créer des produits de plus en plus
précis utiles performant technologique
financièrement viables comme projet mais
ça ne parle pas à votre cerveau central
en d'autres termes il ne vous inspire
pas une certaine forme d'émotions et de
sensations positives alors vous ne
l'achèterai pas et vous n'en serez pas
les promoteurs
maintenant vous comprenez pourquoi
environ 70% des produits nouveaux
présente une difficulté d'utilisation ou
un échec commercial
nous appelons ça des bugs perceptif le
monde du transport nous offre de jolis
exemple de bugs perceptif qui stresse
terriblement les voyageurs
vous avez tous peut-être été un jour
passagers du tgv
quand vont quand le tgv arrive dans
votre gare de destination
vous vous êtes sur la plate forme et
vous ouvrez la porte et la porte reste
muette elle n'a pas enregistré votre
commande ne se passe rien
rationnellement vous allez vous savez
qu'elle va s'ouvrir et que le train va
partir en vous gardant à l'intérieur de
du tgv mais vous ne me sentais pas
vraiment alors que et le stress monte
bien sûr alors qu'un seul un simple
signal vous aurez rassurer et
tranquilliser un petit voyant lumineux
qui juste explique qu'il a bien
enregistré la commande et qu'on attend
pour la mécanique donc se voyant
lumineux parlerai à vous à vos sens mais
pas forcément à votre raison allez on va
rester dans le monde du transport
est ce que vous mettez en place une
petite stratégie d'évitement
quand vous rentrez dans le métro pour
éviter de toucher la barre centrale
savez la barre en inox huppert brillante
et lisse
sauf que quand toutes les masses y sont
accrochées elle devient tiède glissante
moite grâce alors forcément c'est pas du
stress là qui vous prend c'est du dégoût
et l'inquiétude de récupérer tous les
microbes des précédents voyageurs alors
ça c'est un super grand classique du
bugue perceptif qui rend votre voyage
forcément déplaisant et qui quelquefois
vous oblige à prendre un hubert alors là
la matière de la barre a été modifié à
présent elle est beaucoup plus sèche
elle est beaucoup plus accrochante et la
perception du voyageur lui permet de
d'imaginer qu'elle est plus propre
alors à présent c'est bien les exemples
que je vous présente mais l'expérience
c'est mieux alors à faire quelques
travaux pratiques qui vont mettre à
l'épreuve notre intelligence sensorielle
et nos souvenirs
vous avez tous sûrement proche de votre
siège
un petit pot
attentes autour d'anthony
on a dit d'expérience alors ce petit pot
c'est le petit pot de lacolle maternelle
qui vous a préparé quand vous étiez vous
en maternelle sous le regard
bienveillant de votre institutrice
l'adulte que vous êtes aujourd'hui
alors c'est une très longue histoire
enfin facile ce petit pot et d en 1930
il est toujours fabriqué en touraine il
est toujours fabriqué en touraine est
toujours utilisé par les écoliers et il
est terriblement sensorielle on vienne
l'entendre immédiatement
alors d'abord la vision c'est le plus
facile
regardez ce petit pot que vous
connaissez cléopâtre on peut
s'enorgueillir
il est unique depuis 90 ans
sa forme est inchangé son volume et sa
représentation graphique à peine modifié
c'est exactement comme le flacon numéro
5 de chanel qui depuis un à un depuis sa
création est toujours le même et tout le
temps modifié évoluer en fonction des
étés des années vérifiez le son ça on
l'a déjà fait petite musique formidable
regardez on pourrait faire un concert
c'est bien on est à l'opéra petite
musique formidable qui annonce quelque
chose de bien plus intéressant encore
l'odeur respirer
odeurs d'amande odeurs d'amande et
d'enfance vous devenez proust rappelez
vous il nous a dit le donneur et la
saveur reste encore longtemps comme des
âmes à se rappeler les difficilement du
souvenir voilà vous êtes en maternelle
le toucher regarder la petite spatule
elle est en osmose complète avec la
colle qui est dedans
et bien c'est pour faciliter
l'apprentissage à la motricité fine et
la réussite à tout coup du collage et de
l'oeuvre d'art du petit maternaide vous
a été merveilleux comme artiste enfin le
goût
qui n'a jamais goûté la colle je vous en
avais quasiment tous manger c'est un
mélange de fécule de pomme de pommes de
terre et d'eau donc pas de stress mais
une pensée émue est rétroactive au
goûter improvisé vous avez fait ce
jour-là alors pourquoi on a fait cet adn
sensorielle que nous venons décoder
ensemble pour développer ce qu'on
appelle une signature sensorielle et
pour développer avec cette signature des
nouvelles gammes de produits attachés au
patrimoine de cette colle et pourquoi on
a fait ça au bout du compte pour
utiliser d'autres ressort que seulement
la performance technique et
technologique pour rivaliser avec des
atouts humains face aux grands groupes
internationaux de colle je repassais une
pme rien de notre intelligence qu'ils ne
soient passés par nos sens alors
aujourd'hui être super innovant c'est
pas forcément être seulement
digitalement connectés c'est pas
seulement être technologiquement à la
pointe mais c'est savoir utiliser
décrypter les sens et les émotions pour
mieux guider la raison est designer
c'est être inventeur d'expériences
positives pour le quotidien des gens
c'est des expériences qui mélange
perception sensations émotions pour un
design qui ne tient à presque rien mais
qui révèle tout alors cette approche on
peut la faire à toutes les échelles les
machines-outils par exemple eh bien si
nous désirons nous si nous dessinons une
machine outil
c'est pour augmenter la bonne impression
de sécurité à son utilisation pour les
voitures quand vous fermez une porte
d'une voiture de luxe ou de premium et
bien le bruit de la porte va vous donner
la sensation d'une voiture de luxe
quand vous avez le toucher soft
du tableau de bord de cette même voiture
ça va vous rassurer dans votre conduite
jusqu'aux produits de beauté le ressenti
fluide et non gras d'une crème
ça va vous redonner et développer d une
meilleure estime de vous même même les
tramways sont sensorielle je vais vous
donner un seul exemple le confort
thermique
une question un problème est il possible
de garder une température constante dans
un tramway quand les portes s'ouvrent
toutes les deux minutes
non l'été il fait chaud et l'hiver il
fait froid
un autre sujet vous vous en que vous
écoutez tous les bulletins météo et vous
savez que vous donne une température
réelle et une température ressentie
eh bien nous avons travaillé sur la
température ressentie dans les voitures
du tramway nous avons design et la
lumière en changeant la température de
la couleur des sources lumineuses
ça se voit pas mais justement l'hiver
une lumière plus chaudes vous donne une
sensation particulière l'été une lumière
plus froide pour gagner environ
globalement deux degrés de ressentis et
bien l'expression du design sensoriel
tient à presque rien vous voyez pas mais
apporte un confort réel alors si on
essayait ensemble de partager et de
relever les défis de l'intelligent
sensorielle d'abord je vous propose de
redécouvrir nos madeleine tous pour
préparer le terrain de cette
intelligence et puis je vous demande de
d'échangés de comprendre les mécanismes
pour retrouver une forme de simplicité
et de liberté de pensée et de consommer
et je voudrais qu'on redonne à
l'intelligence sensorielle la place
qu'elle mérite dans nos vies alors
pourquoi on en vient d'en faire
l'expérience
parce que ce qui ne varie pas chez
chacun de nous c'est le désir d'être
confortés rassurer affirmé dans ce conte
est ou ce qu'on aimerait être
alors si on arrive à développer ces
trois éléments
on trouvera des solutions qui inspire
les sensations et les émotions
deviendront les vrais moteurs d'une
société dans laquelle on vit
on apportera plus de performances plus
de durabilité plus de prospérité
on sera prêt à développer une économie
du désir merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]